good morning everyone good morning
Millennials how are our favorite
millennial you're going through maybe
someone out there can help you I
currently can't get into my Instagram
account which is so many different
problems they send me an email link I
click it it doesn't work password reset
all this garbage nothing works
it's only gonna half-hour so I'm not
like freaking out freaking out no no no
I don't want I'm fine okay cuz the
sequel is never as good as the first
movie yeah especially when the sequel
gets derailed by a personal problem no
no but I'm I'm totally fine they still
only premium content if anybody watching
works for Instagram please contact me
and help me after the show and just from
what I've seen like it doesn't seem like
there's something majorly wrong it's
just like somebody's not connecting yes
something that's missing something is
missing yes I agree well we have so much
going down on today's show for you today
cuz not only is blonde Cher and he's
gonna help me helping you get informed
this morning we are gonna talk about a
couple major things that have happened
recently and then Kathryn Cooper from
southern term Savannah will be joining
us later but there's too much to get
through before we can even go there
there's two things I want to I want to
start talking about first of all I know
if you're aware of this but today is the
three year anniversary of us in
Nantucket being on the boat this weekend
this day Wow being in tune or not in
tune with what's necessary we have a
couple photos we reminiscent from our
trip we were such cuties back then are
we showing photos we're showing photos
on the show that's so fun like like us
in front of like that restaurant at
night is that the one wearing an
anchored shirt no actually I mean
there's myself even me on the boating
near in the background and you can might
be able to tell behind the sunglasses
that I'm dead on the inside anyway so
it's just it's just a big day for us
there was a really fun trip we should go
back I know Claudia would never you know
she would never go back I would go back
we went to see Dan Humphreys band mother
mother sir
mo mo th em li mo x t mo t HX r I think
it's mo th XR whatever safe to say that
because you don't know it it was a flop
but I'm pretty sure it's putting on some
mother but Y the X its mother concern it
was all it was all terrible it was all
pretty terrible baby like we literally
made memories that will last a lifetime
and that's what trips are all about yes
treacherous or not but when you break it
down we went to Nantucket to see Dan
Humphrey in a c-list band for sure but
the trip was fantastic we were working
it was a free trip like surround it
struck and so even though we didn't have
the best time we never like felt badly
like we spend so much money because it
was free
we were working it was yeah oh yeah oh
yeah I remember anyway those are the
days good times those were the days we
need to like get back on it you know we
need to make new memories cuz the only
thing worse than like not having new
memories is telling the same stories
over and over again totally and we're
not there yet but I could so see a
really close close I agree but in honor
of our three year anniversary today's
show will be very in tune with what's
necessary if the little boy who was
anchoring the boat if his dad's watching
just know that we are in tune with
what's necessary I wonder where that
little boy is now probably three years
older still in Nantucket he's probably
like that one's you puberty like even
less in tune with what's necessary yep
and getting yelled out left and right
yep what's his mother who was going to
lose his father no mean guy son you are
not in tune with what's necessary
um I can't deny shanked also I've been
obviously last time you were on the show
it was great and I was so excited to
invite you back but there was something
that happened that I needed to get to
the bottom of what happened which is why
the major reason Meyer here okay
Harrogate at Noble oh yeah are you okay
I'm okay because if anybody follows me
on my Instagram rest in peace you see
that the next day I had the best meal of
my life so it was counteracted bullets
let's focus on Nobu
let's focus for people that don't know
yes but people that don't know Claudine
and I went to Nobu had a meal I liked
every meal that I have I
take pictures of it like going across my
tuna like oh this tuna looks great and
then like I get my next dish
ooh this fluke looks great I eat it I
enjoy my meal I leave the restaurant all
of a sudden I'm checking the ends and
everybody's like then there is a hair in
your food hair hair hair hair hair I'm
like oh my god and I go back I look at
the photo at the video and there is a
curly hair in my food and you know it
was not yours because you filmed it
right when they put it down there wasn't
time for it to be there was not time for
it to be mine people are saying like oh
it looks like one of your chest hairs
yeah but I think it was a little more
curly it was not my hair they had just
put yeah anyways personally that's my
worst nightmare I have to be honest I
don't know I think if I thought it
happened to me like I would have gone
home and threw up the end like just
seeing the hair in the toilet bowl so
the reason why I don't care that much is
because I know that we all inhale hairs
of other people on a daily basis we in
Harris in Harris it was really gross but
like I don't know the whole idea think
about soup I eat so much soup and then I
think about the fact that like I get
soup from the corner diner
we're like can we talk about like sexual
things like yeah they totally like just
chuck their loads straight in that pot
do you want a more disgusting story that
might make you feel better about what
you experienced and it happened to me
and and so makes it even worse okay and
I'm not gonna do Fame the restaurant
because I actually do like it but I once
ordered soup from a restaurant I ate the
whole thing
yep this is so disgusting I'm gonna
throw up and I'm so sorry and once I was
done I like felt something stuck in my
gum and it was a small hair yeah how
horrible is that's gross that's gross
yeah that's gross so stay away from to
make your own soup anyways I'm waiting
truly like I want nobody to do right by
you in a pot and either apologize or
like give you a free meal because
that is an atrocity I've been we've been
a tonton like I've been like four times
in the last month it's a great
restaurant it's fine now that I have a
hair it's done it's it's over
I actually it's over I definitely won't
go back to that location but like
downtown is a totally different vibe but
they have their own problems it's over
for me
yeah okay well I'm really sorry that
thank you for making me relive it and
draw attention to this issue that's
plaguing restaurant goers nationwide it
is yes and it's just so crazy hair nets
without Instagram and like you know this
whole like foodie culture you never
would have known never really eaten it
going on with my life this Luke was not
I'm not gonna lie my life would have
been better if nobody told me because
they just would never have known
whatever instead it's like this whole
like now I just have like PTSD every
time I see a piece of fish I'm like ooh
now there's a hair tree growing and
you're there could be oh my god I think
you actually eat a lot of here cuz its
CEO like because he's a hair oh yeah
Claudia always makes fun of me for the
amount that I clear my throat but in
reality I probably have just like fur
balls caught in my throat because Pheo
does not sleep with his mother he sleeps
with his father every single night
curled up in my armpit which is so cute
but like there's so much hair in my
throat for sure that's brewing in the
chat right now do you think that Nobu
took down your Instagram it could be no
I don't okay that would be some Fiat
twist that would be some feel we're
getting a lot of questions for you are
these uh Claudia's dirty jeans five days
in a row actually they were not ripped
and I had a fatal fall not fatal I guess
cuz I'm here but I tripped on my way
here you're lying
no my trip I tripped these are no these
are not Claudia's jeans they're my jeans
I like trying to be like on-trend and
cool sometimes like sometimes I'll wear
like white shorts and a bright
short-sleeve button-down right or
sometimes I'll wear like ripped jeans
like cool kids do you find that now that
you're
losing weight and that you've lost a lot
of weight that your style is evolving no
well my style just looks better than it
did okay like they're really the fact
that I wore these jeans 20 pounds ago I
don't even want to know what these jeans
look like on me 20 pounds ago cause
right now they're still tight that's
crazy
right yes I know are you gonna get to
the face and we're gonna have to start
buying new clothes oh you're so good I
did that I did that once and it was a
huge mistake
yeah counting your chickens yeah I I
didn't even
it was even worse I loved some of my
clothing and I had it tailored like I
just had like a like let's say was a
size 36 jeans made into a 33 breathe you
just say your size on the show oh is
that is that brave yeah well right now
I'm back to a 36 but at one point I was
at a 33 at one point I was at a 38 you
were out of 33 like years ago years ago
remember the one minute that I was
skinny yeah when he came to Colgate yes
I and those I had all of my jeans made
into size 33 and now they are just
literally archived
it's like art I just have like thousand
like literally thousands of dollars
worth of clothing just sitting there
that nobody can wear you gotta get rid
of them cuz you know what I realize even
if you when you get back to that size
and you can fit into it you're gonna
want to buy new clothes because you're
gonna be so excited so you're not I'm
gonna wear your oh boy you should just
get rid of that should get rid of really
when you move that's a great opportunity
yeah excited to move yes because we are
busting out of that apartment it's you
can attest evencio his toys are just
everywhere there's no room for toys for
the boys none no room our luggage is in
our living room we have no room I know
I'm excited for you guys to make the
next move on to the next chapter we're
bustin out except I'm gonna miss being
neighbors it's gonna work
true true mmm okay are you ready to hear
the fast side story yes you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast yes are you ready
I'm ready
it's it we should play like some music
like are you ready she likes like with
that is there like a yeah we could or
you could provide the music I understand
yeah but no once I check my phone
oh you can't I can't I can't check him
out okay our first story is really sad
and breaking news but Aretha Franklin
the Queen of Soul has passed away at the
age of 36 76 I'm sorry she's not 36
she's an older woman this news was very
made me very very sad I feel like she
took a turn very very quickly hmm
like she was not sick for that long and
I think she literally just went into
hospice like yesterday like last week I
believe reporting on it and it's very
very sad like we like Queen of music
literally yeah she's like Queen of Queen
of Soul Queen of Soul she's in every
single Bar Mitzvah ever ever and will be
forever
she's like it and that's the kind of
legacy you can only hope to leave is
like you will be at every major a happy
occasion for people for the rest of
their lives
yeah like bar mitzvahs are literally
sent around playing music that makes
people happy like that is what that
music does here are the beats Aretha
Franklin died Thursday at her home in
Detroit following a battle with cancer
her publicist confirmed to the AP the
Queen of Soul was 76 years old she was
born in Memphis Tennessee in 1942 the
daughter of a pastor on a civil rights
activist she has Lee left an amazing
legacy and she will be greatly missed I
did not know that she had cancer I don't
think I realize that either it's just
really sad then maybe she didn't take a
turn that quickly perhaps not but maybe
we just didn't have all the information
because it's actually none of our
business none of our business right
no but anyways this is just gonna beat
this is a big loss for the music
community I really feel like it's the
end of an era you know cuz she was just
so iconic and understand it's hard to
find talent like that these days as you
can see we are all struggling uh so this
is a big loss for greed do you want to
sing the little tribute of respect of
respect
RESP Ct say little prayer
[Music]
it's not from what Disney movie I don't
know they put in a Disney movie they
have they have good taste overuse me uh
yeah and honestly we're not doing home
taxes so maybe just go a run Spotify
because this isn't a truss I can't I
can't sing Aretha there are certain
things that I can sing she's like she's
too - yeah yeah when there's that level
of talent don't try and sing it just
play anything of talent you were caught
on film
singing with Lauren Elaine and this
weekend yes Josh Groban yes how was that
for you that was amazing
that was really amazing at that point I
was really really drunk so the way that
I'll just like backtrack 10 minutes you
Claudia and Margot Jackie klar Dee and
Margot went down backstage Lauren Alaina
me and maims originally we're not
invited to the party so I'm like [ __ ]
this means let's go and get drunk so we
went
I must have pounded like 10 shots at MSG
did he know he had a beer in a shop okay
I made a map a shot and then we go down
and somehow Lauren is standing there and
she's like I guess we pointed to her
something we go down we get into the
dressing room before I know it I don't
really know how we're just vibing me and
Lauren and I start singing with her you
whip it out I whip it out without the
Groban and I think that I forgot that I
was singing with like such a talented
country star that I really didn't let
her sing much it was really me
she was harmonizing with us but she was
an amazing harmonizer unbelievable I
need to take harmony lessons cuz I'd
recognize that is my role you know here
on the musical morning show it's to
harmonize and you know I I understand
why that is but if I could really get
good at it like she was I really could
compliment like you and Claudia when you
yes hit the big notes totally she was an
amazing harmonizer and that concert was
just incredible
we're so excited because Claudia and I
like really felt like you and Zack would
just love Luke Holmes as well yeah he
was good he was great he was really good
I feel like you guys were like so into
Lorna Lena well I didn't see that one
coming
I've never been to a concert at a venue
like that we were in Madison Square
Garden where it was the first time that
that person had been in a concert venue
like that like Lauren could not stop
crying on stage and it was just like she
wasn't jaded she was genuinely like
excited to be in this moment which you
never ever see when he got to have any
of that sighs do you know like Madison
Square Garden is always like okay I know
I'm great that's why I just sold that
25,000 tickets I've made it she was very
like oh my god I can't believe this is
happening like constantly taking deep
breaths and then just killing it I got
was really really so impressed she was
she was great like blue combs just like
knows he kills it
yeah got up there I was like I've been
at MSG before it was just yes he has
been oh I think how did we miss him yeah
he was really good really really good
he's great he's just got that swagger Oh
music swag okay next story
I know we've sort of trying to talking
about them but I just found this
headline really interesting and I feel
like you would be into it Pete Davidson
can only afford groceries in ariana
grande 16 million dollar apartment
ariana grande is definitely the
breadwinner in her relationship with
Pete Davidson but Davidson is the bread
keeper the SNL star admitted to GQ that
Grande purchased their reported 16
million dollar new york city pad but
he's in charge of the groceries that
explains why they're always at Whole
Foods quote she's really sweet she's
like this is our house and I'm like
you're very nice for saying that thank
you for letting me stay here he said
she's like we're getting married and I'm
like I know thank you for letting me
stay here they're still decorating the
apartment and are in need of some
flatware it's like we have six bean bags
but we have no Forks you know what I
mean yes I do
we're learning how to be adults we're
having a really fun time that's really
cute
it is relatable it is I don't know about
the bean bags but I understand not
having Forks and it's like you're
engaged you're not gonna register for a
nice flatware right now but then it's
like you don't have Forks totally I'm
gonna go shopping with him I feel like
he's a good grocery shopper no he's way
too skinny the two of them are too
you need to know what's good totally
just seamless right it's like easy
he doesn't like they say they had ESP
for groceries but like that's all
relative because the two of them are so
small and frail but that doesn't really
add up too much but if he were paying
for the groceries in my household you
know he he might have to take out a loan
also let's be honest he doesn't need to
pay for anything no but you know you
want to feel you want to feel good you
know I know so they're there their age
their family it's just just family makes
it makes it better but you know he is
also a star very successful so he could
pick up the check of here and there he
can but like they just in order for that
relationship to work they just need to
get like they're one person otherwise
he's always gonna be get caught up and
it's clear that he like doesn't care
which is great but they're just some
people that you can't compete with I
also appreciate the clarity um on why
they have 16 medics because if you watch
their snapchats and stuff like they have
this huge apartment with no furniture
and now I guess we understand why
because they're like in this limbo of
being engaged and having beanbags now I
want to beanbag honestly yeah but we'd I
don't understand like so they moved into
this apartment and like they're just
they're figuring it all out they're
figuring out how to adult and honestly
decorating an apartment is a huge part
of a dump and hard by [ __ ] couch no
it's really hard you can't just buy a
couch when you're on Grande like you
have to have a decorator like you need
wallpaper you know no I know but like
you can the first thing you can do is
just buy a couch yeah or 16 bags I guess
I guess where would you recommend buying
a couch from where would you recommend
buying a couch
gallery I have the best couch in the
land have you been to my apartment no I
fun-packed Margo and Olivia have lived
in their apartment for two years I have
never been sensitive nope never been
invited Jackie and Zac moved in eight
months ago now never been to their
apartment it's not daddy it's not ready
to be shown it's ready ooh now it's
ready I'm having an all-girls night yeah
literally screw you how many times you
just come over knocking in the middle
and I looking for somewhere to stay what
how many times you call me up say and
see she's number one we've need you to
take care of Theo goin down the block
can you please pull over by the way
cherish it while you can
I know because once I'm uptown there are
gonna be people closer I
your aunt's teaches number one because
you are down the block well you'll see
that's where my true colors work all the
way out and teachers everyone never
sleeps okay uh no matter we are far
wherever you are takes is my nephew it's
true I will never change it sure so it's
like 20 blocks
I'm not saying in the grand scheme of it
and a couple avenues those avenues are
what they kill you yeah anyways what
were we talking about our is where I got
my couch you would love my couch okay
expensive um I don't even know like how
much coats are supposed to cost like how
do you get a not expensive couch other
than like picking one up off the side of
the street you know I don't know I was
like median price like ours our current
couch was from Macy's okay which was a
good deal but yeah it's still very
expensive right like Annie can you get a
couch for like under 1,500 bucks I don't
I mean I'm sure that you can no can you
get like a nice like a new a new nice
couch
it's tough new nice comfy couch a comfy
yeah
comfy is key yeah you can look nice but
can you sleep on it
my current couch looks nice you can't
sleep on it but you guys are gonna get a
new couch when you move right yeah does
anybody want to buy my couch a new nice
comfy couch for less than $1,500 it does
exist
it does exist it's it's called result
yeah it's called secondhand it's not new
but it smells like me and like might
have one or two of my boogers under it
you know what you can sell them on eBay
the boogers three bucks three bucks a
bug people are saying you can get a
little over 400 on Wayfair got a
sectional it's beautiful you can get a
couch for seven and it's comfortable I
looked all over Wayfarer you guys I
don't know I didn't see what you're
seeing
interesting interesting okay look
anyways next time you do bunch on the
toast you should come over a little
early for a cup of coffee I'll make you
a nice coffee and then you can you can
get the Grand Tour okay that's that
sounds nice yes okay speaking of homes
you can now live in Bela swans house
from Twilight for three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars about three
things Bella Swan is absolutely positive
first Edward was a vampire second she
was unconditionally and in revit
complete in love with him and third her
house is for sale okay that was
unnecessary the film featured as Bella's
home in Twilight has been listed for
three hundred and forty nine thousand
nine hundred dollars so one hundred
dollars shy of thirty three hundred
fifty thousand dollars I love when they
do that it's like $99.99 yeah but you
wouldn't buy it if it was a hundred it
plays with your brain that's crazy
it's true though after years of being
used in all five of the films from the
franchise Bella's house as the family
calls it has four bedrooms and two baths
in the 2500 square foot single-family
residence which underwent a slight
redesign for its use in the films of uh
where is it is it in Forks and it's
gotta be I'm just trying to figure out
where a twenty five hundred dollar house
is selling for three hundred and fifty
in Oregon and here's the thing I just
don't get a twisting because this isn't
the Cullen house which is like a glass
mansion this is Bella's house where she
like had a lot of sleepless nights with
her dad you know yeah I can't think of
anywhere that I'd want to live less
right I want to live in the Cullen house
so when that goes on the market let me
know I mean I don't want to live in any
house that was used in a spooky movie
that's super spooky it's pretty spooky I
guess vampires and like weird [ __ ] I
guess I don't know I'm not like a huge
Twilight guy but I've seen them and they
they're spooky at its height I was into
Twilight but now it's like a place on FX
all the time and I just I can't do it
anymore
have you seen the movie the internship
with Owen Wilson yes it's fine great
movie great movie love it I recommend
everyone just to watch it for some good
laughs it's almost as good as the intern
which I loved but also great but so
different that's no different and that's
what makes them both so great I think
that movie great that movie is great
that movie that's a tear to your eye
Robert De Niro and yes yes and I
expected that to stink well Nancy Meyers
knows what's up he's a great movie it
was a great movie she but watch the both
of them but the internship like just
really makes me want an internship at
Google yes hilarious but I'm not googly
enough I don't think I'm too introverted
mmm but you know Rebecca she works at
Google she is so googly I feel like
you're it's pretty good she's so googly
she's so outgoing and like she's cool
but she's also like
approachable yeah she's like Queen
Google like she's googling yes so
compared to her I've got no googliness
in me but I think you're pretty googly I
could be you could be googly anyways so
just maybe one day okay
my fourth story I would never have
chosen but because it's it's for you
okay I want to get your take on it it's
a very blunt story okay Fat Joe walks
out of a steak house over dress code
issue rap legend Fat Joe walked out of
Ruth's Chris Steakhouse in Greensboro
North Carolina and last night when one
of his entourage his outfits was deemed
in compliant with the establishment
strict dress code you didn't even tell
me about the story I have so many things
to say quote ban Ruth's Chris you think
at that Joe was not appropriately
dressed for your restaurant shame on you
businesswomen in socialite Lauren
ridding Jerry posted on Instagram along
with a picture of her and the rapper in
which he is wearing a chiffon chai tea
but we hear the issue that was actually
that someone in his posse was wearing
track pants
you mean joggers they were offered a
private dining room in order to solve
the issue and give them privacy but
chose not to eat there the dress code on
the restaurants website says business
casual and that proper attire is
required right so where would you like
me to start start from the beginning I'm
gonna take a back seat and because I
can't remember as you say because there
are two pieces to this one is fruits
crisp which I don't know if you've told
the story of Ruth's Chris but we have a
lot of new viewers Claudia's told it so
please tell it okay but work should I
start with dress code start with Roose
Chris okay
picture it 2011 Cody and I are just just
starting to get not 2011 2013 Claudia
and I are just starting to get hot and
heavy we decided to take our first
vacation to the rico puerto rico which
was and will be again our favorite
destination clothes warm you don't need
a Pampling english driver's license
driver's license it's fantastic we go
there at the time
times are tough we're staying at the
Intercontinental you just got kids yep
just a couple of kids looking for a
cheap ring we're eating we're having a
nice time we go downstairs and we
stumble into this steak house and it was
the greatest meal of my whole life
we could not stop talking about how I
got a like a pan crusted halibut caught
he got a fillet it was just divine
I go after I call my mom I'm like mom I
just had the best steak meal in my life
this place Ruth's Chris it's
unbelievable like you have to come to
Puerto Rico to try it she's like been
brutes Chris is like the biggest steak
chain there is one on 42nd Street so
that is my story of Ruth's Chris I
thought it was indigenous to the island
of Puerto Rico how do you top there are
90 of them you guys thought it was like
a Puerto Rican restaurant called
ruthless it Chrissa
[Laughter]
okay thank you for that so you're a fan
of Ruth's Chris love but the second I
have an issue with a dress code I have
an issue at the place I am with Fat Joe
and I can I went to a restaurant once I
was wearing a hat they wouldn't let me
in without wearing my hat you know the
problem with that is why are you wearing
a hat because you're having a bad hair
day correct where you didn't do your
hair right so your hair looks worse
under the hat correct so when I take off
my hat it ruins my night I'm and dress
code I'm sorry this is not the 1930s but
you can look cool and business casual
not wearing a suit like if you're not
going to the plaza roots Chris is not
the plaza and neither is the place that
I'm talking about which I will not give
some bad PR - okay well I moved two
minds on this cuz on the one hand I
appreciate a dress code as someone who
dresses up for everything except for the
airport cuz you guys treat us like
animals so I'm gonna look like an animal
like it's nice when you go to a place
and everyone else is dressed up and like
you know people these days really don't
dress up and it's a problem of our
generation everyone looks like a slob
but they look like a slob and they're
wearing nice designers for example like
that's the difference announced to me
Matt like sneakers regular Adidas
sneakers are not the same thing as Gucci
sneakers like know that the person went
through the time to get dressed up it's
not your version of dressed up no you
know what I'm saying as well so that's
that's
this is my sect so first of all I like
the art of dressing up and you know at a
steakhouse
I appreciate that there they're trying
to keep it that way but then there's
like this new era of street where where
Fat Joe's wearing a Siobhan Shay t-shirt
and personally I think that that is
acceptable it's like the Doreen Erica
Jane mosquito t-shirt dress straight off
the runway saga like I thought erica was
totally dressed appropriately even
though yes she's technically wearing a
t-shirt that's the style she's wearing
with boots you know she went ours like
that's exactly been ours getting ready
it's not that she phoned it in it's just
like that's the style right now so I
think the Givenchy t-shirt is acceptable
but I also do appreciate a dress code
but now Ruth is sick Chrissa is saying
that someone in fact Joe's Posse was
wearing track pants now this is a whole
nother issue because if you talk to she
by Sheree joggers spring/summer it's
what's happening and if you choose
wearing track pants with a heel and you
know if you if you go and revolve any
time like you know that that's the law
then that's appropriate but it's like
it's all about how it's dress and it
becomes subject to just your your own
opinion yeah it's not black and white
so it's case by case and then that's how
people get offended when they're like
who are you to say this isn't nice
enough hundred percent also just a word
to the wise Fat Joe and his posse or any
celebrity and their posse are gracious
enough to walk into your [ __ ]
restaurant and give you PR you don't
look at what they're wearing they're
celebrities they they transcend dress
codes in my opinion I don't know if I
agree with that and also Ruth is at
Chris I did offer that in a private room
and they wouldn't take it so they were
just like so insulted but like that okay
now lifehack wear a shitty outfit to a
restaurant and you'll get a private room
yeah that that part is like that part's
a little weird yeah like take the
private room they're trying to do right
by you and you probably would've gotten
a free meal right especially if you
found a hair in it post-meal mm-hmm I
should start bringing a hair you don't
have to oh no I don't have to like go to
my garden of hairs and just like anyways
I just feel like this brings up a larger
issue within our society of like people
dressing up you know and what is
acceptable because also like if you look
at the Kardashians they're a prime
example it's like they wake up at 6 a.m.
to start getting glam and then they go
out and Kim's wearing biker shorts a
sports bra heels and a sweatshirt
technically I wouldn't call that
business casual but it's fashion you
know so what's it like it's tough it's
tough it's it's a hard line to draw in
this side current fashion world where
like activewear is high-fashion yes you
know yes I just think it's this is a
larger issue it goes beyond ruthless a
Krista and Pat Joe you know they're
really there they hit the nail on
something here they did they did they
did so when you go to a steak house what
do you wear this whatever I'm wearing
now I usually wear a actually t-shirt
jeans or button-down jeans it's not I'm
not I'm wearing whatever like I'm not
thinking about the restaurant I'm
thinking about what's after the
restaurant where am I going that night
right like the the restaurant is not
your night that's where you eat and then
you start your night the steak house if
I go to I mean I don't need steak or go
to sneak houses but I would imagine I'd
be going for the meal and then I'm done
like I can't go out with a drawer full
of stage so if that's the case then I'm
wearing a button-down okay and if that
was the case for Fat Joe and his posse
he'd be wearing about men understood and
if you like what would you say is the
best steakhouse in the city just it's
not it's not it's not in the city it's
in Brooklyn but it's Peter lubbers Peter
lubbers is really it's everything they
say it is yeah it is it's it's
incredible but you don't eat non-kosher
steak any no so is that hard for you
yeah and like occasionally I will make
an exception on that steak yeah why now
why does steak that steak is that good
okay I I would never want to break like
what I believe in on something that
tasted like [ __ ] like that's always the
biggest fear it's like oh I'd love this
chicken nugget because I'm drunk like oh
and then you like wake up in the morning
like pitch [ __ ] that tasted like
terrible yeah like why did I waste it on
a chicken nugget like you always want to
waste it on something amazing right and
that is it okay good to know thank you
yes our fifth and final story is also
gonna launch us into our real husband
or crycat because you did watch and
there's a lot of thought I do uh there
are rumors swirling that Carroll rods
well might be joining the view now I'm
gonna take read this story with a grain
of salt you guys after outgoing Rooney
sturckow Roswell was spotted lunching
with top ABC executive near the
network's headquarters insiders became
convinced that Roswell was set to join
the view but network sources tell page
six that she's not getting a spot on the
daytime talk show which is arguably the
only show in town that comes with as
much drama as the one she's leaving
apparently the exact in question is an
old pal a brad swells from when Brad's
well worked for late newsmen Peter
Jennings they were just catching up says
the source nothing more okay I'm not
sure if you guys are aware of this but
Carol Brad's well has been um planting
stories in the media about herself in
the past few weeks about some trip she
took and how she was in such good
spirits like all this really weird [ __ ]
that's like so fake and whoever's
writing it up for her like I hope you're
getting paid well otherwise what are you
doing so this just seems like another
one in like this string of fake fake
news stories about her um I don't think
there's any way she's joining the view I
think she's in no way qualified and from
what I've heard the view was doing
better than it's done in like 10 years
the ratings are out of tight so if it
ain't broke don't fix it and if the
ain't broke definitely don't add
Conrad's well that's just like my take
on this yeah if anyone from the view is
watching and I feel like she went to
this lunch to stir up some [ __ ] totally
like she's going to ABC yeah it's also
tough first first point I actually have
met Carol a couple of times and she was
very nice so like whatever I say nobody
be offended I don't think that she is
the view material and that is that not
at all she could barely hack it on real
houses you're gonna go up against Joyce
it's not even that she's just she's so
quiet and like not it's well it's not
seasoned everyone said she found her
voice I don't think she found anything I
think that she was just like anti
everyone like that she wasn't on she
wasn't on the offense she was just like
who like this person said this like
let's talk about it like we'll go into
last night's episode but like she was
the she was stir in that pot so we're
the straw that started that but like she
didn't contribute anything she was just
the straw well because Sonia says I'm
the soft straw that stirs the drain
careless
the char that stirs the pot you guys
that was just an amusing reference and
it was really good sorry that I missed
it no it's okay it's my fault cause like
you watch last night's episode I really
appreciate you doing your homework for
this show yeah first of all I just want
to say thank you the dolls appreciate it
because it's not really it's fun for me
to talk about real house by myself sure
um what are your thoughts okay so first
of all I'm gonna start with the end and
then go back to the beginning not every
single one of the cast members homes is
up for sale
what are they yet not getting paid and
are they all okay
or are they all getting paid and
upgrading all that I know is that every
literally you know how at the end it
says like what they're doing next like
blah blah blah just rented her home blah
blah blah put it on the market blah blah
blah put it on the market all of them it
was like he was copied and pasted you
know what's interesting about that it's
like I feel like all these women this
season have really gone through like a
rebirth almost or like an evolution and
they're really on the next stage of
their lives and everyone except for a
few who will get to are doing like
better than ever and I think a lot of
that like when you're feeling that way
it's like you wanna I want a new home I
want a new vibe like this is my I'm
feeling younger I want to move downtown
like I'm feeling more settled I want to
buy a place like this home reminds me of
my ex-husband I want to sell it yeah I
don't think that's what it is what do
you think it is I don't know no I think
they're all in it together and they're
like okay if we tell them to put this on
it's great press for our listings and
they'll sell their houses at more money
than they put it out there for well I
just feel like they're making a quick
buck first southern because Sonia is
doing with her townhouse is brilliant
Richard lence renting it out thirty
thousand dollars a month people are
buying it because like first of all
you're getting a town she has a full
townhouse elevator and all she renovated
it so she could list it and not only are
you in the townhouse for $30,000 a month
you're in Sonja's townhouse it's a piece
of history like that's amazing so she's
using that money to like live somewhere
else probably in a small one-bedroom her
daughter's in college she lives alone
she doesn't need all that space it's
really genius and I'm really really
proud of her so that makes sense to me
then Ramona is selling her Hamptons home
is that what they said or like she was
going to they're all yes so if she was
like that also makes sense to me because
it was the home she shared with Mario
and she should sell it and get a new
home
so like the way she decorated it like
looks like a model home and so she's
definitely selling it then Bethany is a
flipper she flips houses she's on a new
show with Frederick's yes regardless of
anything that's going on here they're
women she will always be flipping yes
Dorinda is what's interesting because
she like low-key like lived on the Upper
East Side and like an one-bedroom
apartment and now I guess she's moving
to Midtown I don't know what that means
for her um it doesn't mean anything he
doesn't know but and I also feel like
she rents so what this has nothing it's
neither here nor there
actually maybe she doesn't the only
person not to talk about anybody's
financials that I have absolutely no
idea about him and just insinuating I
think that assuming I think that Bethany
is the only one that we know he's doing
really well I can assume that they get
paid well from the show yeah they also
spend really well living in New York is
expensive that's why some of us are
moving to Cleveland soon totally how did
you tell that story
yeah I'm optically I don't think people
know how serious I am about it
I don't think yesterday I had one of
those days that I was just like yearning
for Cleveland is there somebody in those
bushes there might be we have a special
guest smooth like I was just sitting in
traffic all day in a cab because uber is
non-existent and no a/c and the meter on
my cab was broken so it kept ticking
every three seconds Wow and I I felt
like the Hulk like I wanted you're just
getting more and more angry more and
more angry and I was just dreaming of
Cleveland a Bissell and I've never been
to speaking of ubers and taxis I am a
new via rider and I love it you're here
proud five [ __ ] bucks and it takes
five extra minutes and I get in my car
he had in the front seat if you're in
the back seat and you're sitting next to
a stranger Divya is the front seat no
not even sitting next to a stranger if
you can push to the back back Oh II
never doesn't around if you're the last
person in the car you're in the back
back we've gotta get in the front
actually you know what you guys should
get in the back I'll stand the Front's
great the front escape yeah then it's
just like a free trip yeah I'm glad
you're enjoying it cuz I'm really we
really like blew the lid off of it when
we talk about the uber via taxi
situation
on the last show yeah we were oh I
thought you were saying that like that
led to something yeah no we did we
opened up a lot of eyes we did and what
I didn't say that I wanted to say is
that a few I guess it was almost I was
in high school so mysoline like eight
years ago now when the city like spent
millions of dollars to put taxis in TVs
which is the worst [ __ ] idea of all
time on a number of levels first of all
no one needs to watch TV in a taxi first
of all second of all you don't even play
anything other than your own commercials
and third of all it's nauseating as [ __ ]
and fourth ball was expensive and you
could have used that money on air
conditioning instead taxi drivers are
taking the vents out of their air
conditioning and shoveling them to the
backseat yes if you want to get a breeze
of area it's like stick your head in
this big tin a/c it's the janky [ __ ]
alive and I just I can't believe that
that is it like my marrow New York City
where the greatest city in the world
except for Cleveland and like this is
the mode of transportation that not only
do we have that the government is
pushing on us like this is the way in
the future this big AC vent that's
coming that the driver had to yank
because it's only in the front and shove
it in the back it's like a tunnel if you
guys haven't seen it it's the craziest
thing of all time the issue though to me
is not the taxi TV it's the partition
which is exactly what you're talking
about like when you get an ax nuber
there's no partition I don't know in
other words the air flows back right
instead of having that janky tube the
taxi TV I'm not gonna lie when I'm stuck
in traffic I don't mind watching a
little set from Jimmy Fallon oh my god
it makes me so nauseous when I first
they make money but in turn they should
lower fares because they're advertising
the city's make gotta make a ton of
money from ABC and NBC they're
constantly advertising on there yeah
sure but like they can also advertise on
the side of a bus no they sure they also
do that like there's other cities
selling out this oh my god it's horrible
and but also everyone turns off those
TVs them aside from you apparently I do
I can dig it in no I do anything more I
get nausea doo doo doo
doo-doo-doo-doo which one is that oh
yeah
and I know I love the one with Alex
Trebek playing jeopardy in the cab yeah
like what color but this cab is blank
color like that's like the ooh what is
yellow like the questions are so easy
but and like if you've ever watched
Jeopardy the real questions are so hard
okay we have a lot of questions for you
so before we bring out Katherine I'm
gonna get to a few of them because I
would be remiss if I did not yeah um so
we do this segment called dear toasters
and we give advice to people and a lot
of people have asked you to give your
advice on a couple of the situations
we've okay so I'm gonna give you the
Cliff Notes version guys one girl has a
boyfriend they've been together really
long time loves him everything's really
good but she has a best friend who's
like weirdly like obsessed with him like
just like when they were at her family
cat the friends family gathering like
and the boyfriend was talking to the
friends like family he was she was like
taking videos like oh my like also
almost acting like he's her boyfriend
like just being like third wheel to the
max and like crossing a line like what
would you do she was she likes this girl
she wants to stay friends but like it's
not cool how close are the two girls
best friends since before the boyfriend
yeah I don't know if it's worth losing a
friend over snow but no I'm saying since
before the boyfriend even if even if
they plan on getting married the two is
the other girl in a relationship yeah
is she a little sad I don't know her but
I'm just saying assumes she's a little
sad that would be my guess have a little
sympathy because she is not trying to
steal your man she is just trying to not
lose her friend and she feels that if
she shows how much she loves the
boyfriend then she'll be included that's
my opinion
like it I've seen this before and like
all that you want to do is say I get the
[ __ ] away from my man like he's he's not
yours he's mine but she's not trying to
steal him that being said if she
is trying to steal him caught her you're
a lot more patient than we are it's it's
tough it's tough because you know that
the only reason why the friend is being
such a creepster with the boyfriend is
because she's hiding something
I mean securities that's a totally
different story okay if she's in love
with him then you got to tell her to
back the [ __ ] off
I don't think that's one of this I
appreciate it um is that bad advice no I
actually like it's interesting because
we Claudia and I pretty much agreed on
what to do and you just have a totally
new perspective which if you're out
there girl listening think about it mmm
um some logistics not your toilet toons
where do you do them is out of your
office don't people hear you it's in my
office and they don't hear me because
the music is coming from the bathroom
like somebody curates a bomb-ass
playlist with every single day like the
music transcends all generations from
rap to like 30s fiddle like it is
unbelievable music and the only reason
why I don't do it all the time is
because sometimes people love my toilet
tunes and sometimes they're like all
right like we know that you're taking a
dump and this is gross yes like they
can't tell if the people really like it
I understand well I actually was in
bloomingdales the other day um and I was
in the bathroom and I had my own
experience with toilet turns because the
bathroom attendant was singing and I
wanted to toilet tune to you but it's
just a lot to like it's weird you know
it's a lot going on like had to grab my
phone from my bag which is on the hook
up there and it's like that doesn't work
yeah it's it's tough yeah okay have you
ever thought about starting a foodie
Instagram account no because I just like
it to be a part of what my Instagram
stories are yeah I eat out a lot I'm
gonna show my food I'm gonna try and
make it fun and not like so serious like
with the hair
no not gonna start a separate Instagram
account just gonna keep evolving but
with no job if I ever get back in got it
also you have said before on this show I
believe that sushi sucky is the best
sushi in the city it's not anymore it's
not and so I was gonna ask you is this
place that you went to it is what's it
called it's called
Ishikawa is it new yes
and do you thought to get a reservation
how does it work very hard I think it's
over a month waitlist
incredibly why do you get in I went I
went with Nathan oh and and a client I
would like a worthy so yes he has been
twenty times because he brings his
clients there so I was just like tagging
along and it was the best meal of my
whole life
it is a pretty penny it is you will not
get out of there
under $200 a person but so it's not not
for the everyday it's for the birthday
the special occasion okay but I'm
telling you it is worth it yeah when you
go to a place that's like that expensive
and like that it's not it's not fancy
like that expensive the food is almost
not edible if you know what I mean like
they try and eat so much they like this
is like the king crab leg that's been
sitting under an ancient snail in the
ground and tastes like horse [ __ ] it's
squirrel food
exactly we're like like I once like
pineapples like not pineapple whatever
I've eaten like weird weird stuff when
you go to a really expensive restaurant
because they they just like get the
rarest food to give you the rarest thing
that this guy uses its pounds and pounds
of fresh black truffle and caviar that
is how it becomes so expensive there is
literally just I don't know if you saw
in one of my Instagram stories he gave
me a spoonful of beluga caviar Wow that
I just went down the hatch it was
unbelievable you should all go save up
it is worth it for one meal okay it's
the best if you could have dinner with
one famous person dead or alive who
would it be and why wow what a question
if I could have dinner with one famous
person dead or alive who would it be
it would definitely be a basketball
player because they're the only ones
like really Reb Michael Jordan Kobe Kobe
what would you ask him um Shaq I take it
back
Shaq Shaq and Kobe they can come
together if you play your cards right in
this lifetime you can get to dinner
which I would love to get to dinner with
Shaq somehow
I would talk about everything he's just
a jack-of-all-trades like not only is he
in my opinion the most dominant center
of all time in basketball he is
hysterical he was in movies I think I
mentioned this last time
Kazaam he's a DJ he's just like so cool
and does whatever the hell he wants and
is massive and fun yeah well now that
you've done this twice and you're doing
it again next week yes you're co-hosting
with Claudia great did you know that I
didn't okay yeah co-hosting with Claudia
no it's not gonna be crazy
it's gonna be crazy just because we like
we're just gonna talk over each other
but it's gonna be hella I'm gonna have
to take a back seats am i cuz I really
put you in the O I mean I'm in this
chair you're in this chair interesting
what's good morning what's your side
this side or that side it's good not to
have a side anyways I don't think I'm so
do you have like this hosting bug now
like do you think you're gonna like go
off and start your own podcast i I mean
it's funny that you should say that I've
been in negotiations for four months on
my own podcast it's coming close to an
end that's like a start it's an ending a
started so long they forgot about that
yeah there are a lot of legal hoops to
jump through and contract negotiations
but yes I'm starting a sports humor
podcast that's with two of my boys oh
right I'm not gonna say the name I'm
gonna have a big launch maybe I'll come
here and launch it do any of the viewers
like sports okay
they're well-rounded right so you'll
enjoy this you don't show this thank you
so much for joining us we will be back
we're taking a quick break we'll be back
with Kathryn Cooper from a southern term
Savannah I'm so excited you guys have
great questions for her and we just need
to get to the bottom of what's going on
in the show because like I watch a lot
of reality TV and I think I'm pretty
smart and I've no [ __ ] clue what's
happening so thank you Ben for joining
us thank you for having me I'll see you
next Thursday you'll see the next
Thursday and we will be back shortly
you
we are back with Catherine
from southern charm sadhana if you're
not watching I'm Bravo you absolutely
must because it is such a good show and
last season was great that this season
was even better is even better because
the cast is evolving I like the changes
that they've made and we have a lot of
questions for you about just how the
cast came together and how you got
involved with the show okay I guess when
they were first starting to think about
franchising the show Landen we knew each
other so she kind of recommended that
they talked to me as a liaison in
Savannah to help kind of like figure out
which people would be good to start
interviewing and to do videos and they
kept coming you know be here for a week
and then they'd be gone for two months
and it was like this is never gonna
happen this is fun it's like a great
distraction from actual job and then a
year later all of a sudden it was like
brother like honed in on this group of
people that are actual friends right
from Savannah and we were like oh my god
like jaw drop what problem just picked
up eight episodes like never in my life
did I imagine that actually happening
that's okay that must have been like so
exciting when you started the show like
how were you like skeptical or where you
just like all in ready to do it and like
put your life on TV no definitely not
ready to put my life on TV you know it's
hard because you when you are friends
you know I think it's a very different
dynamic than Charleston whereas you know
they're different age ranges and really
come from you know different cities but
when you're from Savannah you have your
parents your grandparents you know
everyone so it's a little hard to put
yourself out there considering this is
your hometown yeah and everybody knows
you and you're friends with these people
not to mention having a camera in your
face and never having done this in your
life right yeah no but you come to it
really well like your interviews are
always so funny and I feel like you're
you just have like a good personality
like for television if you like people
really are liking you and that must be a
good feeling I hope they like me yeah
hard to watch yourself on TV and like
deal with the feedback both positive I'm
negative if it's definitely hard to
watch myself on TV I can hardly listen
to my own voice mail so to hear my voice
every Monday night I'm like oh God
something have marbles in my mouth half
the time I'm mumbling but no I mean it's
gonna feedback I think like you were
saying earlier you know you have lots of
questions because there's a lot of
confusion I think people are confused as
well right so it's like hard to know
which direction or which side to choose
because obviously we've had five
episodes air but there's still so much
more to come and a lot of those
questions will be answered so I think
people are confused as to which side to
choose right it's very ambiguous which
also makes it a good show because it's
not like you know production is telling
you whose side to be on or like who's
right and who's wrong and there's a lot
of questions there's I feel like this
past episode answered a lot of them or
some of them whereas before it was just
like I feel like there's something that
happened that we didn't see but then we
had Daniel on the show and we're like
what's going on that we're not seeing
he's like we're all asking the same
question - by the way we love Daniel
he's been on the show three times now
and he is a friend of the toast
um so just want to shout out to Daniel
but how was the town of Savannah like
taken to the show have they embraced it
happen I think with any reality show
coming to town they were a little
skeptical you know opening up their
doors people gonna be you know lifting
up tables and screaming at each other no
that's not how it is so once they saw
the first season evolve the second
season they were much more open to oh my
gosh yes please come film here or you
know more like asking for us to film
their verses in the beginning where they
were like no we're good
right but I think they are a little more
excited I mean it's just subpoenas a
small town so I think it's just fun just
to see like your friends on TV it's kind
of like yep people have secondhand
embarrassment for us totally get it but
for the most part I think that's been
well-received that's great at least it's
my face right um
so obviously you have a lot of questions
about human Lyle
at the end of our season he attempted to
propose and that did not go his way um a
lot of people want to know like that was
totally real correct yes did you see it
coming at all no no so
that was hell the reactions right so you
were like upset at him for doing that
well it was one of those things that we
had talked about several times together
and you know when you haven't lived in
the same city for probably ten years you
moved back the second week that the show
is airing you know I had a full time job
trying to manage the show manage you
know I had my own routine for five years
like right that's just you have to get
used to being by ourselves that Monday
through Friday I had my own routine so
you know he comes back you have the show
you have the job it was very stressful
so in those seven weeks leading up to
the final episode that week we had
talked about it was like you know we
need some time to like have a normal
life and really figure things out
without the show and you know he agreed
we had lots of things to kind of
consider and I mean I know it came from
a good place but it was it was
definitely not the right time totally
and I feel like on this past episode
other people of your friend group are
starting to understand that like when
you're having that conversation with
Brandon and he like really starts to see
your side of things a bit I thought that
was just really nice and like
explanatory for the people who really
are like what is going on between them
and it is very hard to explain that as
you can see you know we've known each
other for 15 years and we have been on
and off you know he went to college I
was still in high school
I went to college he came back to
Savannah I lived in New York I went to
Europe you know he went to Italy in us
we've been all over but you know we
obviously have the same friends we've
always found our way back to each other
but for the past 15 years have not been
exclusive but we when we were committed
we were both committed and thank
goodness we've dated other people
because that would be kind of crazy if
you know yeah at 15 you hadn't had other
experiences in your life so yes he's
dating other people I've dated other
people and y'all are just now seeing us
in this stage and you know I think
people have been confused for a long
time but he and I know
it's going on and I feel like it's you
know very hard to express it and very
like detailed language because it has
been so much history right and we don't
get to see that right so where do the
two of you stand right now well if I
told you that I would ruin the rest of
the seasons this is how to watch we will
be watching that's very exciting so um
you have some new cast members this
season mm-hmm
Brandon and Haygood and I'm loving them
like I feel like with any show bringing
on new cast members is always hard for
the viewers for the cast like to just
integrate them but they mesh really well
with the group
I mean Brandon is so funny when we film
I'm like oh my gosh can a not say half
the things you're saying right it is so
funny like guilty by association he is
so funny and he was on it last year with
me and they brought him on full-time and
he has really brought great different
element to the show
I totally sassy and he just is
quick-witted and spot-on about pretty
much every topic he chooses to discuss
right because the rest of the guys on
the show we're like it's hard it's hard
it's hard to watch sometimes and also
they are like man children like them
going out every night and then like
shaming Daniel for like trying to work
out and be a morning person like what's
wrong with that I don't know I guess
they've just known him for so long to
see this immediate change you know
they're automatically calling BS but you
know I think Daniel has really
progressed and the past year and this is
really his new focus and it's hard for
them to get on board because they've
known this party boy for so long right
he's always the life of the party so to
see this side it's kind of like hmm so
this is like a pattern we're starting to
see in the southern charm franchise
where like the men kind of don't want to
grow up want to go out every night till
4:00 a.m. which it's like I understand
like once in a blue moon like a 4:00
a.m. night is so fun
that every night sounds like torture so
is this like a specific to the south is
that why we're seeing it like come up as
an issue on the both shows in Savannah I
mean you know with the guys I think
there is just prolonged adolescence
regardless of where you live and it's
also about the access you know allow
lives downtown Louie lives downtown but
then Dino doesn't live downtown so I
think I mean they both are you know have
great jobs but there's this other side
of them that just wants to let loose and
hit the town I mean I can't do any more
no yeah and I would try to run with them
and I was like I would feel so terrible
and exhales like I can't do it like I
can't run with the big boys anymore they
just like not get hung over like what's
the deal or they just don't go out all
the time I think it's definitely even
when you're filming there's much more of
a tendency to go out and talk about you
know the season and oh my gosh I can't
believe that happened yeah and just a
camaraderie definitely well I'll have to
go back to that because Louie claims
that he doesn't get hungover which I'm
like possible and I know love it so good
right so I think it's just how he
manages it and apparently doesn't get
hungover
oh my god it's only but then like my
whole life would like would go to [ __ ]
just because I wouldn't do anything else
um and then we see it on next week's
episode Ashley it's treating the party
um question mark who invited her let's
see what is this is this the party at my
house yes okay um I actually included
her that's nice of you
yes so she came over Brandon Hannah and
I had a conversation with her and she's
been really trying to make an effort to
apologize about some of the things that
she didn't said last season and you know
everyone deserves a second chance so
it's kind of like here's your chance
yeah that's nice I like that mentality
I'm excited to see it next week thank
you so much for joining us yeah thank
you for having me that was easy
can everyone follow you on Instagram and
snapchat I just I got a new phone so now
I'm about up all my social media yeah
I've got a lot of montant to roll out so
I'm very excited to share my Instagram
is cc oh oh oh PE are confusing either
Oh PR you can watch seven-term semana
Monday nights on Bravo thank you so much
I'm so excited everything played out me
- girl bye oh I am gone leaving no show
tomorrow summer fridays hey I'll be back
next Monday I'm going away on vacation
I'm very excited and you can follow my
vacation journey at Jackie O problems
what we will see you on Monday Claudia
and Taylor Stryker
you
you